[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today let's go
straight to the phone lines where we've
got brinda in Dallas Texas what's going
on
Brenda hi um yes my dad he's in his 80s
and I have determined that he's been
scammed out of thousands of dollars by a
fake Publishing Company shoot um and so
I recently I persuaded him that it's a
scam uh but I still feel like he's very
vulnerable because they'll just keep
calling and keep calling with a new scam
and all of those things a year ago he um
got a call out of the blue to republish
one of his books and so they asked for
money up front and since then they've
just they they've even withdrawn without
permission from his account once they
got his account number oh wow so how
much money are we talking like um right
now it's almost 20,000 oh wow Brenda do
you guys have um contact information for
these people I mean like this is they're
stealing money it's this is illegal have
you contacted the police um no I haven't
really known what road to go down
legally what I have been doing is uh
like uh we canceled his cards and got
new cards and we put in fraud
information with the with the bank and
um he recently agreed to add me to his
bank account um you know I mean he he
wants to leave a legacy for his family
and he's written these books and they're
wonderful books Christian teaching books
and um it's just hard for him he's you
know he's not a child that I can tell
what to do he's a a grown adult and I
don't want to take
away um that but he's very vulnerable
he's easy to persuade and they just keep
calling with different tactics
wow so so I guess my question really is
um because he's written another book and
they want and he didn't tell them
fortunately but it you know it's ready
to go and be published again and he's
basically told me can you find me a safe
place where I can publish this book and
in some respects I want to just shut the
door and say don't do that anymore but
writing is his his Outlet well sure when
you say publishing when you're saying
publishing Brenda do you mean just
printing copies of the book printing
copies of the book and like making it
available on Amazon you know yeah I mean
that would probably check all the boxes
for him right okay yeah and all of
that's not like crazy inexpensive I mean
it's not crazy expensive I mean you
could you could do that I mean it'll
take some you know some work on your end
Brenda to help find a printer and all of
that but if that's his wishes yeah he
doesn't need to be going through a third
party unless you think like oh my gosh
it's like CS Lewis's stuff or whatever
that like he actually could get signed
to a publ a legit publisher and do this
I don't think that's really what what he
wants to do necessarily well and I don't
think I would trust it at this point
yeah no no no I know I know so so yeah I
think you guys need to print yeah some
some copies and have a few boxes to give
to the grandkids I think you can
probably put it on Amazon that I mean we
do that kind of stuff here at Ramsey
well yeah and the main thing that he's
asked me is you know um
um can you find me somebody that can be
kind of like my agent and and in respect
to that I feel like if he had somebody
that he knew was a legitimate
trustworthy
publisher then he would be less likely
to fall into the Trap of those that are
untrustworthy and pursuing him
constantly um thought about getting him
to change his phone number and
everything but um what if he got around
it kind of sounds like he's trying to do
a lot of this in a vacuum what if he got
around some clubs like and started uh
getting to know a group of writers to
where everybody's kind of looking at
each other's stuff and everybody's kind
of sharing contact information and it's
a little bit more of a trusted
environment where it's like have you
used this guy yeah I've used this guy
like how you know how did you get your
book on Amazon this how I did it and it
kind of did a community approach as
opposed to I'm just like going down the
yellow pages and I'm going to pick a
publisher and I'm like that does feel
very you don't know what you're going to
get and he's 80 years old Brenda I mean
what's your do you like like what do you
think his his motivation like what do
you think this is in him has he always
wanted to do this it's not to crush his
dream there's also a reality that you're
80 and you know me this may not be your
big break right I mean I I don't I don't
understand if there's a unhealthy part
of him trying to be somebody is there
anything like that or is it just
genuinely he loves what he's writing
about and he wants it available for
people to read right like I'm like I
wonder what his motivation is in all of
it well and his first book that he wrote
is a kind of a teaching book on
Christian um foundations and um the
driving Point behind creating the book
was to use it in a church setting and he
did use that for years and at some point
he wanted to take that material and put
it together in a book form and I think
his desire now comes from all that
happened with that years ago and so now
he's written another book that's similar
to that and yet another one um and he
lost his wife um my mom in January and
uh he just really needs something yeah a
great Outlet grab on to give and focus
yeah so what I would do Brenda if I were
you is I would sit down with him and say
Hey Dad listen here's what's happened
you have been scammed out of almost
$20,000 we can't keep doing this it's
not wise dad so any big money decision
that's happening anytime you want to
spend money will you just run it by me I
just want to talk through it make sure
that I can maybe like Run course for
some of this uh to be able to help you
because I want you to to you know if you
have this dream and have this content
that you want published and and out into
the world like we can get that done like
we can do that we also need realistic
expectations of what things are in life
and we don't want your legacy to go down
the drain financially by making bad
mistakes and so we I want to I want to
honor you in that and help you in that
as your daughter but also let's be wise
and any big financial decision D like
let let team up with me and let's talk
it through together create your free
every dooll budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life